so I will confess I have a little bit of
a trick that I use when I watch other
people spin that tells me almost
instantly how skilled they are no it's
not the difficulties of the tricks they
use no it's also not how many tricks
They Know believe it or not it's
actually how slowly they spin I know
seems like an odd pick but stick with me
here cuz I'm willing to bet you anything
that I can convince you that when it
comes to slower spinning this is the way
Drex here from Drex Factor po sharing
with you the love of pois spinning and
flowarts to benefit your body and brain
and today I'm going to share with you
why I think slower spinning is not only
a sign of Greater expertise with po but
also something that we should all be
striving for and some exercises as to
how you can achieve it but before we
dive in I just want to give a quick
shout out to the Friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk flow fests flow
toys pyro Tera light toys and Ultra poy
for helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non- buus friend of the channel Becca
becklen thank you so very much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission now I've certainly noticed and
perhaps you have too that many novice
Spinners tend to think that spinning the
poy is almost like a race the faster
they go the more exciting exciting it is
but when you compare them to people
who've been spinning for many many years
if not more than a decade you'll notice
that there seems to be a much more
relaxed Tempo to their spinning and I
don't think that's a coincidence for one
thing being able to spin slower means
that you have more control over the POI
you have more ability to be able to dial
in the tempo that you want with them in
addition it usually means that you
probably have conscious control over
when and how you spin the poy this is
actually a really important skill for
getting from beginner to intermediate
spinning and because I'm just that
helpful I've already done a video on
that topic that includes a bunch of
drills that help you achieve what I
consider to be beat control I'll link to
that video down in the description as
Wells up in the cards but beyond that
the ability to spin slower is also
directly correlated to how far a
performer is willing to extend their
arms away from their body as they're
spinning the POI inexperienced POI
Spinners tend to keep their hands much
much closer to their bodies and it's
only after a lot of training and a great
deal of effort that they become
comfortable enough to extend their hands
all the way away from them okay so if
slower spinning is is indeed the goal
how exactly do we achieve it I'm so glad
you asked because I have selected three
specific exercises to help you get there
so let's check him out before we dive in
if you like videos on PO spinning and
flow Arts pretty please make sure to
subscribe to the channel and ring the
bell so you know exactly when I upload a
new video thanks in advance all right so
our first exercise is going to involve
using a tool that I've become an
extremely big fan of in the past year
and that a lot of people around me are
probably sick of hearing me talk about
and that is pen pendulums specifically I
want to take these big pendulums that
are also sometimes called extend Lums
around if you move your hand around in a
circle but you keep it below a certain
speed you'll find that the poy head can
never get above your hand now the funny
thing is this is actually the exact same
path that your hand follows if you're
going to perform either an extension or
a flower it just so happens to be that
you're putting less energy into the poy
as you go around so your first task here
is to go back and forth between two
different driving Styles namely those
extend Lums as well as those extensions
that is you're going to try taking
energy away from the POI to get to the
pendulums and adding it again to get
back to the extensions try and think
that you want to get in one two three
reps with the pendulum and then one 2
three reps with the extensions before
coming back to the pendulums once again
you want to go back and forth like this
10 times overall this is going to teach
you much more control in terms of how
much momentum you're putting into the
poy plus which over time I can just
about guarantee that the speeds of the
pendulum and the extension are going to
start to drift closer and closer
together as you practice it over time
and of course you want to practice this
in all four timing and Direction modes
so taking your pendulums around and
together same three times with a
pendulum and then three times with an
extension three times with a pendulum
and three times with an
extension next up you're going to want
to switch two together opposites once
again start off with your pendulums do
three reps and then switch to three reps
of extensions before returning to your
pendulums again once again go back and
forth 10 times next we'll do the same
exercise in Split times same direction
which admittedly is kind of weird
because it means that we have to do it
in wheel plane for the first time
instead of wall plane but I think with a
little little practice you'll find that
it'll feel just about as comfortable as
it does in wall plane again three
pendulums and three extensions 10 reps
and our final timing and Direction mode
is going to involve going in Split time
opposites once again you're going to
give me three pendulums and then boom
bump yourself up to extensions for three
reps and then back down to our pendulums
this is actually the hardest version of
this one to me I always miss the point
where you make the transitions happen
but with a little practice you'll get to
notice those moments where the hands
come together to either side as being
the spots where you can switch back and
forth awesome so now that you've had
some basic practice adding and
subtracting momentum to the poy I want
you to go ahead and start playing around
with different volumes and try to match
different volumes of poy to the same
beats let me show you what I mean here
we're going to start off with just the
pois spinning together same in front of
us and I'm going to choose my left hand
to go around in big circles my left hand
does an extension my right hand just
keeps on spinning down by my hip the
challenge here is to make sure that
they're both spinning at exactly the
same rate now this will mean that the
left- hand poy is probably going to spin
just a little bit faster than I would
like and the right hand poy will spin
just a little bit slower but when you
find a balance between the two you will
have found a place where you can slow
down your spinning just a little bit to
match that bigger Circle and of course
we want to switch off which hand is
doing the big circle and which one is
doing the small circle to make sure that
both of our hands are getting trained
how to slow down and beat match a bigger
Circle and we're going to want to try
doing this in other timing and Direction
modes so I can go two together opposites
and once again decide that I'm going to
try this exercise with my right hand
doing a big circle and my left hand
doing a little circle from here I can
switch off and have my left hand do the
big circle and my right hand do the
little circle you want to make sure that
both po going up and going down at
exactly the same time and then things
get interesting when we get to split
Time same direction because now we have
to keep the timing in Split time well at
the same time making sure that both of
the PO are spinning at exactly the same
speed once again I'm probably going to
find that the hand and po that are doing
the big circle are probably going to go
just a little bit faster than I would
normally like but I'll also find that I
am slowing down the PO in the small
circle and getting a better feel for the
range of tempos that I can spin it at
and of course we want to make sure that
both hands get a chance to be the big
circle and the little circle as we
practice this and we'll do the same
exercise in Split time opposites once
again we want one hand to go big the
other hand to stay small and to continue
to match the tempo of each hand we want
to be able to let the right hand go big
and we want to be able to let the left
hand go big again find a tempo where you
can find a happy medium between the two
all right so if both of those first two
exercises are feeling comfortable then
it's time to do our third exercise which
involves no trickery whatsoever we just
have to actually change the speed at
which we are spinning our POI all right
so here's the important part of this
exercise you're going to have to keep
track both of when the POI is furthest
beneath your hand as well as when it's
furthest above your hand I would call
these the down beats and the upbeats the
reason being you're going to try
spinning your POI at a comfortable speed
and you're going to count the down beats
1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 and then you're going to
try slowing the PO down so that the two
rather than being the next downbeat then
becomes the upbeat so looks like this we
go from 1 2 3 4 to 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 like
so and just like all our other exercises
we want to practice this in all timing
and Direction modes so I'm going to
start off in together same here in wall
plane in front of me and think one 2 3 4
and switch to 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 you'll
note when I go to halftime like that two
things happen number one I'm probably
going to have to extend my hands moving
up and down at least a little bit and
also too it's going to look like the
tethers go a little bit slack as I'm
doing this and that's okay the purpose
here is being able to add being able to
spin this slowly to your toolbox not
that the PO look perfect as it's
happening and once again we're going to
do this in together opposites I'm going
to think 1 2 3 4 and then go 1 2 3 4 1 2
3 4 like so split Time same direction
thinking 1 2 3 4 and then 1 2 3 4 1 1 2
3 4 slowing them down to Half Time like
so all right now we're going to finish
things off in Split time opposites this
is usually the one that I have to cheat
just a little bit on because things get
kind of dicey when the poy are kind of
meshing together like this but let's see
how it goes I'm going to start off
thinking 1 2 3 4 and then 1 2 3 4 1 2 3
4 just like that cool when you can get
down down all four goodness you got a
long way towards achieving an enormous
amount of control over the poy so go
forth and slow down your spinning not
only can it make you look a lot more
graceful but also too the amount of
control that you learn in the process is
worth it in the long run did you get
anything out of this video please make
sure to like comment share and subscribe
to help other people find it and to help
my channel grow
[Music]
this video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on patreon in
particular I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you so much all
of you all totally Rock and if you out
there watching are not currently
supporter but you'd like to become one
here's how you can sign up to my patreon
head on over to patreon.com drexfactor
PO and sign up there you can get access
to a whole host of awesome rewards but
even better than that you'll be
supporting me in my mission to bring po
spinning and flow Arts to the whole wide
world so go check that out please and
thank you and if you'd like to learn
more about another important po skill
that I like to refer to as beat control
I will include a link to a video I did
on that topic down in the description as
well as up on screen thank you so much
for watching make sure to get out and
flow yourself today and I'll see you
with a new video real soon take care now
peace